des crises migratoires à la frontière
entre la biélorussie et la pologne sont
lise des milliers de migrants et sont
toujours mais c'est dans l'espoir de
passer en europe on retrouve sur place
notre envoyé spécial david khalifa
bonsoir à vide on est particulièrement
ravi de vous retrouver en ce soir
puisque vous avez été arrêté ce matin on
le disait vous avez passé de longues
heures en garde à vue avec jandy demory
votre caméraman vous allez évidemment
nous raconter votre mésaventure dans
quelques instants mais tout d'abord un
mot sur la situation sur le terrain des
familles entières david dein originaires
pour la plupart du moyen-orient
s'apprête à nouveau à passer une
nouvelle nuit dans le froid
effectivement elle stéphanie de ce qu'on
a pu voir de ce qu'on a pu entendre en
tout cas depuis ce qu'on est arrivés on
estime à plus de 2000 le nombre de
migrants à cette frontière polonaise des
migrants pour la plupart qui vont devoir
une nouvelle fois affrontées ce froid
glacial un froid qui frôle le négatif et
les 0° un à chaque nuit il ya donc les
barbelés ils y allaient les familles
épuisées les enfants je les ai surtout
cette présence militaire cette présence
policière qui est assez intense 1 du
côté polonais comme je vous le disais un
une cinquantaine de migrants ont réussi
à traverser la frontière ce week-end une
dizaine ont été arrêtés ce chiffre qui
fait froid dans le dos dix seraient
morts jusqu'à présent en selon elle les
autorités locales nous étions ce matin
dans un petit village qui est se nomme
ou nash gorny à une centaine de mètres
un de la frontière avec la biélorussie
où de nombreux migrants ont tenté de
traverser une nouvelle fois cette cette
frontière sans réussite pour la plupart
les contrôles les contrôles frontaliers
sont sont très fréquents les contrôles
policiers sont sont assez intenses il il
vérifie chaque voiture ils fouillent les
cov pour voir si des migrants ne s'y
cache pas je vous le disais les temps la
tension est assez palpable si bien que
le ministère de l'intérieur a envoyé des
messages à tous les portables étrangers
qui se trouvent aux abords de la
frontière avec la biélorussie un des
messages avec des directives très
claires un des directives qui indique ne
tentez pas de traverser la pologne pour
atteindre l'allemagne épargner votre vie
épargne et votre santé en clair rentrez
chez vous et puis cette décision du
gouvernement polonais significatif
significative d'une tension palpable
puisque un mur va être érigé à partir du
mois de décembre en tout cas les travaux
vont commencer à partir du mois de
décembre
coût total de ce mur 353 millions
d'euros il devrait s'étendre sur
181,1 km soit la moitié de la frontière
qui sépare le pays avec la biélorussie
et david on disait en une journée très
mouvementée pour vous aussi puisque vous
avez été arrêté ce matin en plein direct
par les autorités polonaises
effectivement c'est finir ce qui s'est
passé comme je vous le disais nous
étions dans ce petit village à qui ça
qui s'appelle ou nash gorny ce petit
village se trouve à une centaine de
mètres de la frontière avec la
biélorussie nous nous installions avec
mon chéri mon journaliste reporter
d'image ordi de bris pour faire un état
des lieux de la situation avec ces
migrants à cette frontière pour raconter
ce qui se passait à partir du moment où
notre caméra était sorti a été à peine
déposée sur le sol un camion de police
est venu à notre rencontre ce camion de
police nous a priés de façon assez
sévère il faut le dire deux d'orange et
notre matériel d'art était d'enregistrer
1 ce conte ce qu'on avait prévu de faire
à partir de ce moment là ils nous ont
prié de monter dans le car et tout ça
avec les menottes à la main les menottes
à la main pour aujourd'hui de mourir et
moi-même ils nous ont embarqués dans ce
car de police pour nous amener dans un
commissariat non loin de deux jeunes à
corgnac komisarek s'appelle socalled
gars soccal cas excusez moi pour la
prononciation voilà à partir à partir de
là nous nous sommes rendus dans une
petite cellule assez exigu ouh là les
policiers qui nous ont interpellés ont
pu taper alors leurs procès verbaux dans
un premier temps est de notre côté nous
avons tout de suite demandé ce qu'il
allait en être pour nous sans réponse de
leur part en nous disant qu'il fallait
attendre une traductrice cette
traductrice par chance est arrivé aussi
vite que possible sinon on devait passer
48 heures dans une cellule 48 heures de
garde à vue ainsi si jamais la
traductrice n'était pas arrivé à partir
du moment où cette traductrice est
arrivé toujours les menottes aux mains
je précisais évidemment nous avons pu
être interrogé chacun notre tour
séparément à jordy de mourir et moi-même
un interrogatoire qui a duré à peu près
une heure chacun après cet
interrogatoire nous avons pu nous rendre
à la cour de justice où un juge à a pu a
délibéré de notre car voilà ça a été
jusqu'à à une cour de justice a pour
vous dire l'ampleur l'ampleur de la
chose à noter que nous avons n'avons ni
leurs parents durant un ca 9 heures de
garde à vue on puisque on peut estimer à
hanover le chiffre de cette garde à vue
a c'est assez dur il faut le dire c'est
assez avec beaucoup beaucoup de tension
avec beaucoup de sévérité également de
la part d'un des policiers qui n'ont pas
été d'une grande gentillesse avec nous
quoiqu'il en soit après ce jugement qui
a duré à peu près une heure où nous
n'avons pas nous n'avons pas pu prendre
d'avocat a été d directement dit l'or
lors des gardes à vue qu'on ne pouvait
pas prendre d'avocat ça aussi ça a été
un peu particulier puisque on n'a pas
compris sur le coup pourquoi on ne
pouvait pas faire appel à un avocat on
nous a clairement expliqué que c'était
une procédure accélérée que donc nous ne
pouvons pas faire pouvions pas faire
appel à ses avocats le verdict a été
donné au bout d'une heure au bout d'une
heure on our nous avons écopé d'une
d'une amende ou de 10 jours
d'emprisonnement si nous ne payons pas
cette amende qui nous a été transmis des
nous a été écopé à savoir que mon
confrère aujourd'hui de mourir ici même
n'a plus de passeport puisque les
autorités ont gardé son passeport et il
nous leur rendrons une fois on aura
réglé cette amende cette amende à ces
éleveurs un prix assez élevé pour pour
le coup et une fois que l'on aura pu
payer cette amende est bien et nous
rendrons ce passeport et nous pourrons
de nouveau circuler dans cette zone
puisqu'il faut savoir que nous sommes
interdits à de zone nous sommes
interdits d'aléas sur cette zone près de
près de la frontière à savoir que des
médias à d'autres médias ont connu cette
même mésaventure inde et des confrères
de arte par exemple où il a été très
compliqué hein pour eux de sortir de cet
isolement en tout cas voilà juste pour
le simple fait de nous défendre à chaque
reprise où nous interrogeait j'ai pu
dire que nous étions seulement des
journalistes que nous étions là
seulement pour informer donc des
criminels ça a été assez mal perçu de la
part du juge qui a dit que no no no no
justification était quelque peu naïve
voilà est ce qui s'est passé en gros
j'ai essayé de résumer un maximum mais
voilà au terme de neuf heures de garde à
vue nous avons pu enfin sortir de ce de
ce calvaire et nous sommes là pour vous
raconter ce qui s'est passé et on en est
évidemment ravi david kelly fin merci
également à jordy demory à vos côtés